I wanted Tomas well yeah you're the
ladies do too much we have this guy John
now we can Hitler hair crime John eyes
closed he's like the Tomas from another
context yeah yeah this is the most Asian
guy I've ever seen in my life look at
his face it's like it's like that you
could buy like statues of him at like
you know the airport in Beijing the face
of Beijing yeah yeah yeah okay you have
a real [ __ ] face right right and your
dick is not good that's what this kind
of show that's what the shows about
well no I look then I'm I'm like I'm not
comfortable with the way you're talking
what's the deal with bananas are they're
yellow they're weird yeah yeah
that'll be a billion dollars please do
you feel weird when like African
Americans like they you because they
call each other the n-word and all that
kind of stuff that doesn't does that
bother you or no it's none of my
business
exactly so I can call him ching chong
I'm sorry that's none of it it's like I
want to have a language and a way to
talk to other Asians yeah that why
people can't say yeah what about
Mandarin that would there are so many
images that perhaps you could use with
fellow Asians nobody right Gilbert does
that be cool to have late in English so
that people can understand what you're
doing yeah and then have them feel like
uncomfortable but all that's the way
they have their own way of talking wait
wait are you doing a white person voice
there is that that voice that is it I
was you know it's it's absolutely true
but while I'm around
like if it was just me and him here I do
like oh isn't it such a relevance oh
look at your cracker doesn't that feel
good calling him cracker no I felt bad
[Music]